Dutch parliamentary elections in 1 minute
let's go in the Netherlands we have 1 constitutional
monarchy with 1 parliamentary system
difficult words for royal constitution
first second room
and the November elections are about the latter
the second parliamentary elections
in that room we have 1 more party system
with proportional representation
1 proportional representation means 10
of the votes equals 10
of the seats
the seats are the chairs in the room
a total of 150 seats have been given
so you get 10 of the votes
you get about 15 seats
in this second chamber there is a vote on it
bills and 1 bill is passed
when more than half of the second room
so more than half of the seats
agrees
as you see here
there are no parties that get 76 seats on their own
that means parties
have to work together for 1 plan
to make where the country is coming
years to go
this happens in the coalition
1 cooperation of the parties
which together have more than 75 seats
parties that are not in the coalition
are in the opposition
1 important addition
so you vote for the people who will take those seats
these persons belong to parties
so your seat still goes to the party
but you vote for 1 person
okay but what does that mean
why is this important at all
there is no absolute majority
so there is no one who really wins
in our elections
there is 1 big party
but it still has to
cooperate with other parties
to get anything done
2 votes for 1 small party matters in the Netherlands
maybe they don't rule
they can always make west proposals
3 we do not vote for the prime minister
long story short
Dutch politics is collaboration and poldering
include this in your choice of who you will vote for at 22
November okay
almost 2 minutes sorry already